Ferrari Lamborghini simply the ultimate
in vehicular Lemuria right well in Italy
Lamborghini started out associated with
tractors so how did Lamborghini evolve
from killing the fields of Bologna to
becoming one of the top luxury brands on
the planet through a personal insult
delivered by this man mr. Ferrari
himself influenced it
monix Emperor's owner
[Music]
Ferruccio Lamborghini was a real man
with real skills as an Italian Air Force
mechanic during World War two he set up
a little auto repair shop in northern
Italy buying surplus military machines
and converting them into tractors he
made a lot of money for the Miata
multiple discs so much money that he
could finally afford a Ferrari 250gt a
true side that he had made but there was
a problem so he took a trip to visit
Enzo Ferrari himself to complain Ferrari
notorious for writing off his customers
through shade as a tycoon tractor maker
exclaiming the problem is not with the
car but with the driver go focus on your
tractors game on Lamborghini was furious
about Ferraris fiery affront and decided
to build his own car just to spite him
Lamborghini poached a few of Ferraris ex
employees and told them to get to work
on beating their former boss at his own
game the team succeeded with the result
being the Lamborghini 350gt and the rest
is history
FXX Collier I already said that
you
[Music]